ben tre
[拍手]
あなたの私を見たときの第一印象は何でしたか
多分車椅子の人だと思います
そりゃそうです私の見た目の中で一番インパクトのあるところだと思います
でもこの話が終わった後にあなたが私にイラク印象はきっと全然違うものだと思います
今日はそれを楽しみに聴いていただけると嬉しいです
5年前私の人生はどん底に落ちました
エンテロウイルスというウイルス性の脊髄炎にかかり
歩くことができなくなったのです
私は小学校2年生の頃から父の仕事の関係で東南アジアにあるベトナムという国に住ん
でいました
そこでの日々は本当に楽しくて毎日が輝いていました
しかし
中学校1年生の10月1日のことです
朝起きた時から下半身に猛烈な痛みが襲いました
今考えると
あの痛みのまま中学校行こうとした自分が怖いですが
皆勤賞私は狙っていたので
何とか我慢して学校まで行きました
1時間目私のクラスは授業の時間を使って3階のホールで遊ぶことになりました
朝からどんどんどんどんいたみやま市なんとか私は手を使って階段を上がりました
授業が終わる頃
ついに耐えきれなくなった私はその場に倒れたのです
担任の先生が保健数まで運んでくださりそのまま現地の病院に救急車で向かいました
しかしその病院にいるままでは検査ができないので急遽
隣国のタイに行くことが決まりました
結果的に大で1か月ほど少した私ですが
その時はできるだけ早くベトナムに戻りたいというふうに思っていました
心配してラインをくれた友達にも大丈夫だよという風に非常に返事をしていました
その時は事の重大性を何も理解していなかったのです
病院ではウイルス性だけど悪性じゃないから
また歩けるようになるよというふうなことを言われていました
当時の私は何ですぐにやらないんだと苛立っていました
結局ベトナムに変えることなく11月ごろ日本に帰国した私は京都の病院に再入院し
ました
ここでは全力ダッシュとかは厳しいかもしれないけど
ランニングくらいならできるようになるよと医師から言われた記憶があります
病院でのリハビリが始まってからはなんだかタイにいる時のリハビリとは違うなと思っ
ていました
そこでも1か月ほど過ごした後大阪にあるリハビリに強い病院に転院することが決まり
ました
私はもう一度歩けるようになるためにリハビリを強化するのかと意気揚々としていまし
た
しかし現実はそんなに甘いものではありませんでした
そこでのリハビリはタイで行っていたものとは大きく違いました
タイでは歩くためのリハビリをしている感覚だったのですが
そこで行ったのは京都の病院で行ったものに近く
靴を履く練習やぺの力でダンサーを上る練習など
そんな練習が多かったです
私は理解したくなかっただけ
きっと分かっていたんだと思います
これが再び歩くためのリハビリではなく
車椅子生活を送れるようになるためのリハビリだということを
モヤモヤした気持ちが続く中原因した12月からいつのまにか2ヶ月の月日は流れてい
ました
2月一家
忘れもしません
私に
宣告が下されました
現代の医療技術ではもう一度歩けるようにはならない
医学の発展を待ちましょう
そんなことを言われました
先に泣いたのは一緒に話を聞いていた母でした
私は驚いたようで実は心の中で薄々気づいていたことを言語化された気がしました
泣いたのは母がいた何分か
難病カードでした
それから今まで5年と2ヶ月
ずイベント長かったように感じます
くらい杏仁させてすみません今日はそんな人生真っ逆さまに落ちた私が見つけた
自分の殻を打ち破る方法についてお話しします
中学校2年生の時退院した私は5名監事2学校に入学しました
今では立命館宇治が大好きな私ですがその当時は学校に行きたくなくてしかたがなかっ
たです
親に車で送迎してもらっているのですが学校近くのコンビニを見ると毎朝動悸がする
くらいには学校に行きたくなかったです
学校に行くどころか生きているの際やで
でも死にたくはなくて毎日
砂のように消えてなくなることはできないかと思っていました
けれど一度行くのをやめてしまえばもう学校にいけなくなると思った私は辛い中なんと
か通い続けていました
学校に通い続けられたのは
学校の先生方や家族立命館宇治優しいみんなのおかげです
例えば何人かの友達が毎朝学校の駐車場まで来て私は迎えに来てくれたことがありまし
た
おかげで教室まで向かう心の余裕がすごく生まれました
出来ることがあれば何でも言っていっ
先生からも登立からも何度も言われた温かい言葉です
思えばいつも私の周りはみんなの細やかな気遣いで溢れていました
支えてくれたすべての人にはいくら感謝しても足りません
なんとか学校に慣れてきたかなと思い始めた中2の11月
また別の病気にかかってしまいました
iga 血管炎という病気でエンテロウイルス脊髄炎とは何の関係もないそうです
せっかく頑張っていたこれまでの自分をもう一度叩き潰されたような感覚がしました
なんで自分がそんなことはキロほど考えました
どん底から抜け出しそうになった私を別の病気がもう一度底まで落としていったのです
でもそんな時も応援メッセージをくれたり連絡をとってくれたりする
学校の先生や友達は私の心の支えでした
3年生になる4月から医師からが登校許可がおりもう一度学校生活がスタートしました
これは2年生の頃から感じていたことですが学校のみんなは部活などに加え勉強に加え
てもう一つ何かを一生懸命頑張っているなぁと思い
それを私は身近で見ていました
それと同時に勉強さえまともにできない自分は何なんだ
自分には何もないと思うようになりました
自分もがんばってみようと思った最初のきっかけでした
みんなに追いつきたかった私は3年生の最初の中間テストまで本気で勉強することにし
ました
加えて英検や関係など検定も何度も受験しました
全部みんなに追いつくためです
努力が実った1学期の中間テストそれまで学校の先生に中の中と言われていた私がなん
と学年トップ10に食い込みました
少しだけ自分の存在価値を感じることができた瞬間でした
でもまだまだこれじゃだめだという気持ちもありました
周りのみんなは勉強をこなしつつもう一つ
昔 now 別の何かに全力投球していたからです
あれ勉強なんて頑張った当たり前なんじゃないか
勉強しかできないなんて自分は面白くないやつ
そんな風に思っていました
勉強以外に何か頑張ってみたいでも自分がいることで誰かに迷惑はかけたくない
でもやっぱりやってみたい
歩けない自分を言い訳にして負の連鎖に陥っていた自分がいました
今ではあの頃朝鮮お好み続けた自分に腹が立ちます
私の学校には海外に行って国際会議やワークショップ
ボランティア活動などに参加できるチャンスがゴロゴロ転がっています
けれどそうの中興味はありつつも言い訳を繰り返して私は変わることができませんでし
た
そんなこんなのうちに中学校生活が終わってしまいました
立命タージ高校に進学した私は4月に決断を迫られます
それは中電とアンバサダーという学校のボランティアに参加するかどうかというもの
でした
そして
ふと思いました
そういうときにどう思って知りたいか
でも死ぬ時のことを考えて行動するみたいななってすごく難しいですよね
そこでもっと簡単に判断ができる時点のアイディアを思いつきました
それが
自分が死ぬ前に事前を書き残すなら何を書きたいか
です
面白いことが書きたい
自分の人生が方になった時に面白くなるような生き方がしたいそう思いました
極論で動いてやろうと思いました
そんな決断で支柱電探馬サダーになることを決めた私は2年連続で優秀賞をもらえる
くらいアンバサダー活動を楽しく行いました
勉強以外に何か頑張れることを見つけることができ自分の存在価値がより高まったよう
な気がしました
そして高校2年生の11月
私の人生の中で最も大きく強い決断がやってきました
それは
生徒会長に立候補するかというものでした
対立候補がいるということはすでに分かっていましたし何より車いすというハンデが
あると役割を全うできないのではないかという心配もありました
当時は周りの目もすごく怖かったです
立候補受け付けが終了するギリギリまで悩みましたが
自分が死ぬ時に自伝を書くなら何を書きたいか
という判断基準を思い出しました
その基準で考えるともし選挙に負けても挑戦しなかったよりも面白い事実が掛る
それに車いすの生徒会長って面白いと思いませんか
そう考えると立候補への決心がつきました
結果生徒会長に選ばれたのは私でした
ここで学校でのみんなの私へのイメージは車椅子の人から生徒会長へと一気に変わった
のです
生徒会長として頑張ろうと意気込んでいた私を襲ったのは
コロナウイルスでした
掃除を読む予定だった先輩の卒業式には出席禁止
学校にも行けず実施したいプロジェクトの夢が音を立てて崩れていきました
それでも私はこの中で最大限の努力を尽くしてきました
例年5月開催の体育祭は延期になっており9月の文化祭も怪しかったです
しかし私の学校は体育祭や文化祭への想いが人一倍強い人が多くそこが輝ける場所で
ある人もたくさんいます
そのためどちらも中心にせずできるだけ
例年の規模を縮小させないように行いました
最大限制度の気持ちに寄り添えたということは本当に良かったと思っています
周りの学校がどんどんオンライン開催額に変更していく中
強さもありましたが
どちらも生徒に楽しんでもらえるイベントにできたことは生徒が会執行部として本当に
大きな功績だと思っています
生徒会長以外にも自分が死ぬ前に自伝を書き残すなら何を書きたいかという判断基準が
も出た私は
これまでの自分だったら絶対にしていない決断を多くしてきました
ここまで聞くとこの判断基準を持って行動できている私は何でもうまくいっているよう
に見えますが実はそんなことはありません
コロマの影響で学校に行けない日が続いていたときまだ一度も学校に通いていない1年
生たちのために何かできないかと友達と話し合っていました
そこで私とその友達で
先輩にオンラインで質問ができるイベントを開くことにしました
何度もその友達と相談し青根リー先生からの協力を仰ぎ
プレゼンテーションやポスター当日の流れまで考えて準備万端で挑んだそのイベントに
はなんと参加者が1人もいませんでした
とてつもないショックでした
自分が死ぬ前に事例を書き残すなら何を書きたいか
という判断基準に従って行動したところ大失敗したわけです
でも私はやってよかったと思っています
これっぽっちも後悔はないんです
やらないで終わると
事前にはやらなかったそれしかかけません
やって失敗する
これならそれまでの計や自分の気持ち
失敗した原因などいくらでも書くことができます
やらないで終わるよりやって失敗する方がずっとずっといいのです
そしてこの大失敗大いに反省した私は今別のオンラインプロジェクトを行っています
この中で留学がしにくくなった今オンラインで海外の学生とつながろうというものです
まさかの参加者ゼロという失敗から学んで生徒がどうやったら参加してくれるか考え
抜きました
月波30人以上の生徒で交流を行うことができました
しかしそこでも新たな失敗が起こります
日本人参加者20人近くに対して一つの脅威つしか設けていなかった為ハウリングの嵐
隣の人の声が写り込む画面が固まるなど提案やがイベントでした
でもこの失敗も私は事前に書いてやろうと思っています
この失敗に公開などなりありません
そして今この失敗を生かして第2回の開催も計画中です
最後に
今の私を5年前の絶望した私が見たら
歩けるようになるめどがついたのなんて本気で聞いてしまうと思います
それくらい私はいま人生を楽しんでいます
どん底に落ちてもう這い上がれないと思っていました
けれどそれを乗り越えていろいろなことに挑戦しアクションを起こし続けてきました
そしてこれからもアクションを起こしていきたいし生き生きとした姿を回りに見せて
いきたいです
いつか自分が死ぬ時に
自分の歩んできた人生が面白いものだったと思えるようにしたいのです
自分が死ぬ前に自伝を書き残すなら何を書きたいかという判断基準を持って生きること
ができているならそれが可能なはずです
何かを決断する時挑戦恐れないとか
変化を怖がらないとか私はすごく難しいと思うんです
怖いものは怖いって
思うことも多いんじゃないでしょうか私はそういうタイプです
決断後の結果で変わることはあっても決断をするそのときに自分の性格をすぐに変える
ことってなかなか難しいと思うんです
怖くて止めようとすることもあるかもしれません
そんな時に
自分が死ぬ前に事前を書き残すなら何を書きたいか
と言う
判断基準を持って考えてみてください
あなたの未来がもっと輝いたものになるきっかけになると思います
ありがとうございました
[拍手]